you're often being asked about a union
of a new project to be asked by three
three minutes ago but this movie proved
that it can revive Graham Chapman
wonderfully by animation and sound
recordings and we know that a Tupac
hologram appears in front of full
stadiums so perhaps there is a new
technology that will enable no and you
too and you a new project so is this
really the closest that we'll get to but
I tell you walking on absolutely
anything which should also bring there a
big part of the group together aren't
you sorry you won't hit on that in your
film absolutely anything yes that's
that's a film right written with Gavin
Scott it's done in gym violence I mean
the you know I understand it has been
published at the Pythons will donate
their voice yes well they were planning
to do we were planning to have the
Titans voicing the aliens but it's about
a man who gets magical powers and can
suddenly make anything happen
and the aliens given this these powers
they intersect the Voyager spacecraft
but anybody there is nothing really to
do with getting quite interesting
science and mightily you have inside
your contact to this project yet but I'm
finding so it said to Terry I'll do a
voice yeah
were made so do that but nothing's
actually signed and I mean the press do
leap on the slightest chance I mean if
we're all on the same planet we know
pythons all together for a reunion
someone Mike Medavoy in Phoenix pictures
told me that he was trying to sell it as
a Python film spent two years trying to
sell it but Bill and Ben are going to
make it in China Bill and Ben single
well double handedly keep Python going
got long ago this is finding odd things
under the desk or bits of paper than be
used to sort of wait chairs down yeah
I'm gonna keep my inheritance
you